atracar su banco para recuperar su
propio dinero el viernes tres escenas de
este tipo acontecieron en Líbano donde
la crisis de liquidez crece desde 2019 y
donde los límites para retirar dinero
dejan a millones de personas sin acceso
a sus ahorros
él quiere lo que es suyo por derecho
entro en el banco buena suerte a él
nosotros como pueblo libanés no
solidarizamos con cualquiera que tenga
derechos no hay violencia no hay quema
nada las fuerzas de seguridad son
nuestros hermanos saben que tenemos
razón por eso no hacen nada el miércoles
otro vídeo se había hecho viral salía
Fest 28 años utilizó la pistola de
juguetes de su sobrino para exigir que
la dejaran retirar sus ahorros
congelados para pagar el tratamiento del
cáncer de su hermana se marchó con 13
mil dólares
no tenía nada que perder
hace dos días fui al director de la
agencia y le supliqué le dije que mi
hermana se estaba muriendo Me dijo que
podía darme 200 dólares eso no es ni
siquiera el precio de una inyección
diaria para mi hermana
estaba el punto de vender mi riñón para
que ella se curará
por los activistas del grupo depositores
que prometieron organizar más asaltos de
bancos
estamos organizando más que esto
ahora no hay otra opción los derechos de
la gente son sagrados
ante la multiplicación de estos
incidentes el ministro del interior
convocó una reunión de urgencia para
tomar las medidas de seguridad
necesarias por su parte de la asociación
de bancos del Líbano decretó el cierre
general de todas las sucursales durante
tres días la semana que viene